PROCESSION AND THE PUBLIC
VIEWING OF THE QUEEN'S COFFIN
THAT'S NOW UNDER WAY.
>> Reporter: SILENCE AS QUEEN
ELIZABETH II LIES IN STATE IN
WESTMINSTER HALL.
MOURNERS FILING PAST, PAYING
THEIR RESPECTS, SOME OVERCOME
WITH EMOTION.
♪♪
>> AFTER SPENDING A LAST NIGHT
AT BUCKINGHAM PALACE, THE COFFIN
WAS CARRIED IN PROCESSION ON A
GUN CARRIAGE.
BEHIND, ON FOOT, HER FAMILY,
KING CHARLES III AND HIS
SIBLINGS, PRINCESS ANN, PRINCE
ANDREW AND PRINCE EDWARD.
AND THE QUEEN'S GRANDCHILDREN,
INCLUDING PRINCE WILLIAM AND
PRINCE HARRY, WHO WE LAST SAW
LIKE THIS WALKING BEHIND THEIR
MOTHER'S COFFIN AS CHILDREN.
ON TOP OF THE CASKET, AS THE
PROCESSION MADE ITS WAY ALONG
THE MALL, THE PRICELESS IMPERIAL
STATE CROWN.
AS IT MOVED THROUGH ICONIC
LANDMARKS IN LONDON, GUNS FIRED
FROM HYDE PARK, AND CHIMES FROM
BIG BEN MARKING EACH MINUTE.
AMONG THE FIRST TO ARRIVE AT
WESTMINSTER HALL, THE QUEEN
CONSORT, THE PRINCESS OF WALES,
AND THE DUCHESS OF SUSSEX,
TRAVELING BY CAR.
WITNESSING HISTORY, THOUSANDS
WATCHING AS THE COFFIN MADE ITS
WAY DOWN THE POLITICAL DISTRICT
IN WHITE HALL TO BE PASSED BY
THE FAMILY TO THE PEOPLE.
MEMBERS OF THE ARMY, NAVY, AND
AIR FORCE GIVING A GUARD OF
HONOR TO THEIR LATE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
THE PROCESSION FINALLY ARRIVING
AT THE HEART OF PARLIAMENT, THE
ANCIENT WESTMINSTER HALL FOR A
SHORT BLESSING.
♪♪
>> THE LORD LIFT UP THE LIGHT OF
HIS COUNTENANCE UPON YOU AND
GIVE YOU PEACE.
AND THE BLESSING OF GOD
ALMIGHTY, THE FATHER, THE SON,
AND THE HOLY SPIRIT BE AMONG YOU
AND REMAIN WITH YOU ALWAYS.
AMEN.
>> Reporter: THEN, FINALLY, A
CHANCE FOR MOURNERS, SOME WHO'D
WAITED OVERNIGHT, A CHANCE TO
HAVE THEIR OWN PERSONAL MOMENT
AND BID FAREWELL TO THEIR QUEEN
AHEAD OF THE STATE FUNERAL ON
MONDAY.
AFTER THOSE EVENTS, WOLF, THE
KING HELD CALLS WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN, ALSO PRESIDENT MACRON OF
FRANCE.
THEY BOTH EXPRESSED THEIR
CONDOLENCES TO THE KING AHEAD OF
THAT FUNERAL.
I CAN TELL YOU TONIGHT, HE HAS
RETIRED TO HIS COUNTRY RESIDENCE
AT HIGH GROVE IN THE WEST OF
ENGLAND, A CHANCE TO DECOMPRESS,
TRY AND MAKE SENSE OF THINGS AND
ALSO RELAX A BIT AHEAD OF THAT
BIG EVENT ON MONDAY, WHICH THE
WHOLE WORLD WILL BE WATCHING,
BUT HE WILL BE CONTINUING THOSE
CALLS AT HIS COUNTRY RESIDENCE.
>> MAX FOSTER, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I WANT TO BRING IN OUR CHIEF
INTERNATIONAL CORRESPONDENT,
CLARISSA WARD, CNN CONTRIBUTOR
TRISHA GODDARD AND THE FORMER
COMMUNICATIONS SECRETARY TO THE
QUEEN, SIMON LEWIS.
YOU KNOW, I WANT TO START WITH
YOU, TRISHA.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
SEEING.
YOU HEARD MAX FOSTER REPORT THAT
THE ROYAL FAMILY HAD DINNER AT
BUCKINGHAM PALACE LAST NIGHT.
HOW IMPORTANT IS IT FOR THEM TO
HAVE THESE PRIVATE MOMENTS TO
BREAK BREAD, FOR EXAMPLE, AND
POSSIBLY MEND TIES?
>> IT'S REALLY, REALLY
IMPORTANT.
I MEAN, GRIEF IS SOMETHING THAT
SEPARATES PEOPLE, BUT ONE HOPES,
ESPECIALLY WITH HARRY AND
WILLIAM, THAT IT BRINGS THEM
BACK TOGETHER AGAIN.
AND EVERY SINGLE TIME THEY'RE
OUT IN PUBLIC, THEY ARE SO
SCRUTINIZED.
YOU'VE GOT BODY LANGUAGE PEOPLE
WATCHING HOW THEY REACT TO EACH
OTHER.
YOU KNOW, HOW DID MEGHAN LOOK AT
KATE?
I MEAN, CAN YOU IMAGINE?
ALL FAMILIES HAVE FALLOUTS,
EVERY SINGLE FAMILY HAS A
FALLOUT, BUT FOR EVERYTHING TO
BE SO SCRUTINIZED WOULD BE VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT.
SO, TO ACTUALLY GET SOME TIME
TOGETHER IN PEACE FOR EVERYBODY
AT SUCH A TIME WHEN THEY'RE
GRIEVING AND THEY'RE COMING
TOGETHER AND IT MUST BE VERY
REMINISCENT FOR THE BROTHERS, AS
MAX SAID, THE LAST TIME WE SAW
THEM WALK BEHIND A COFFIN WAS
THAT OF THEIR MOTHER'S.
SO, THIS IS QUITE A TRIGGERING
TIME FOR EVERYBODY, SO TO BE OUT
OF THE PUBLIC EYE AND TO HAVE
SOME TIME TO DECOMPRESS IS
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT.
>> CERTAINLY IS.
CLARISSA, PEOPLE, AS YOU KNOW,
THEY LINED THE STREETS OF LONDON
TODAY FOR THIS HISTORIC
PROCESSION.
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN HEARING FROM
THESE FOLKS WHO CAME OUT TO PAY
THEIR RESPECTS?
>> Reporter: HI, WOLF.
>> I THINK WE'RE HAVING SOME
TROUBLE WITH CLARISSA'S AUDIO.
CLARISSA, STAND BY FOR A MOMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO FIX THAT AUDIO
AND GET PACK TO YOU.
TRISHA, LET ME ASK YOU A
FOLLOW-UP QUESTION WHILE I HAVE
YOU.
DESPITE THE POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCES AROUND THE NEW
KING, CAN SOME PEOPLE -- SOME
PEOPLE CAN RELATE TO THIS MOMENT
AS KING CHARLES, OF COURSE,
ATTEMPTED TO SIGN A VISITOR BOOK
WITH A LEAKY PEN.
I WANT TO SHOW OUR VIEWERS WHAT
HAPPENED.
WATCH THIS.
>> 13th, SIR.
>> OH, GOLLY, WRONG DATE.
13th.
>> YES, SIR.
>> YOU SIGNED 12th EARLIER.
>> OH, GOD, I HATE --
>> IT'S GOING EVERYWHERE.
>> THIS BLOODY THING.
>> SO, WHAT SORT OF REACTION IS
THAT GETTING, TRISHA?
>> WELL, THAT WAS A PRINCE
CHARLES' SECOND FALLOUT WITH
PENS.
HE HAD ONE EARLIER ON.
AND I ACTUALLY THINK IT'S QUITE
IMPORTANT, BECAUSE I MEAN, I'VE
HAD SUPPER WITH PRINCE CHARLES,
SO I HAVE MET HIM, AND HE HAS
GOT A TOUCHY SIDE, AND I THINK
HE'S VERY, VERY DIFFERENT FROM
THE QUEEN, AND I THINK IT'S
MOMENTS LIKE THAT THAT MAKE HIM
MORE HUMAN, AND THAT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING HE NEEDS AT
THE MOMENT.
HE'S NOT GOOD -- PEOPLE KEEP
SAYING, WILL HE FILL THE QUEEN'S
SHOES?
I THINK IT'S A STUPID THING TO
SAY, BECAUSE THEY ARE VERY, VERY
DIFFERENT PERSONALITIES, AND
IT'S WHEN WE SEE ANYONE IN THE
PUBLIC EYE BE A BIT HUMAN THAT
WE CAN LAUGH ALONG WITH THEM
AND, YOU KNOW, AND THEY JUST
SEEM THAT MORE REAL.
BUT IF I WAS PRINCE CHARLES'S
COURTIERS, I'D BE KEEPING PENS
AWAY FROM HIM FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
>> I WOULD TOO.
YOU KNOW, SIMON, I'D BE ANXIOUS
TO GET YOUR TAKE.
WHAT WAS YOUR MAKE OF THAT
MOMENT, AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING,
BASICALLY, OF THE ROYAL FAMILY
THIS WEEK?
>> WELL, WE'RE SEEING, AS TRISHA
SAID, A FAMILY, BUT WE'RE SEEING
THE INSTITUTION COMING TOGETHER,
AND I THINK IT'S JUST WORTH
REFLECTING ON THE SHEER
PHYSICALITY OF WHAT THE KING AND
MEMBERS OF THE ROYAL FAMILY HAVE
BEEN GOING THROUGH, THAT LONG
WALK TODAY, THE EMOTION OF IT,
THE FACT THAT MANY OF THEM WERE
WEARING HEAVY UNIFORMS, AND THIS
IS NOT JUST A PERIOD OF EMOTION,
BUT THIS IS A PHYSICALLY VERY
DEMANDING PERIOD, SO I'M VERY
PLEASED THAT THE KING IS RESTING
TOMORROW.
ALSO, I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THE FAMILY BEING SEEN
AS ONE.
ALSO, VERY NICE TOUCHES.
PAUL, BIG PAUL, AS HE'S KNOWN IN
THE PALACE, WHO WAS THE QUEEN'S
PAGE FOR, I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT,
ALMOST 30 YEARS, BEHIND THE
COURTAGE TODAY, SO WE'RE SEEING
THE FAMILY, BUT WE'RE ALSO
SEEING MEMBERS OF THE STAFF WHO
SUPPORTED THE QUEEN IN
PARTICULAR FOR MANY, MANY YEARS.
AND I HAVE TO SAY ONE OTHER
THING.
BIG CROWDS NORMALLY ARE VERY,
VERY NOISY, AND I'M JUST SO
STRUCK BY THE QUIET REVERENCE OF
THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
WAITING TO PAY THEIR RESPECTS TO
THE QUEEN.
IT'S QUITE EXTRAORDINARY.
>> EXTRAORDINARY INDEED.
AND IN TERMS OF LOGISTICS, OF
ALL OF THIS, SIMON, IT'S PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE HOW THEY'RE DEALING
WITH ALL THIS.
>> Reporter: IT IS, AND OF
COURSE, THESE PLANS HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE FOR, IN THE CASE OF THE
QUEEN'S ARRANGEMENTS, PROBABLY
20 YEARS.
EVERY SINGLE DETAIL SIGNED OFF
BY THE QUEEN HERSELF.
BUT OF COURSE, IT'S THOSE LITTLE
MOMENTS THAT DON'T QUITE GO TO
PLAN, THOSE LITTLE MOMENTS THAT
NEED TO BE KIND OF SORTED OUT ON
SHORT NOTICE THAT TEST THE
SYSTEM.
AND I WAS THINKING TODAY,
WATCHING WESTMINSTER HALL AND
THE FILING IN OF THE PEERS, THE
LORDS, AND THE MPs, I MEAN, THAT